now police have arrested a woman on
suspicion of child neglect as after four
young brothers died in a house fire in
sutton in south london 66 firefighters
were called to the house in collingwood
road in sutton yesterday evening on
arrival they found only the children two
sets of twins twin boys inside they
performed cpr at the scene but they all
later died in hospital
shortly before 9 pm last night
fire crews were called to a house fire
where eight fire appliances and 60
firefighters attended the scene
we rapidly entered the building and
carried out breathing apparatus
operations to recover and rescue the
four children and carried out cpr at the
scene until the arrival of our london
ambulance
colleagues
the children were taken to the hospital
shortly afterwards and sadly they died
of their injuries in hospital
the cause of the fire is currently
unknown and will remain on the scene
over the coming day
to investigate alongside our
metropolitan police colleagues
well charlotte lomas is in sutton at the
scene
for us that update charlotte um from the
fire brigade there were some hours ago's
desperately sad tragedy do we know
anymore
well you can see the mid terrace house
just here uh behind me that's where the
fire broke out last night where
firefighters quickly attended were able
to get that fire under control within 90
minutes but as you heard they found four
young children inside this building they
were able to rescue them quickly and
administer
cpr but sadly all four children died in
hospital
we know that an investigation is ongoing
we've seen the forensic tent being put
up here in forensic officers going in
and out of the house throughout the
morning hoping to establish the cause of
this fire which is as yet
unknown but we have heard of the
profound impact that this has had on the
firefighters who attended the scene here
last night
many deeply traumatized we've been told
by
what they saw and what they had to
contend with
as too it's fair to say other community
here in south london throughout the
morning we've been seeing lots of people
come and just to lay some flowers here
uh behind me many leaving their tributes
there is one that says sleep well
love grandad extremely moving attributes
that we've been seeing this morning many
people describing just simply how
devastated and how sad they are and
shocked at this news we can listen now
to some of the people that i spoke to
earlier on
it's quite a close community
and everyone
does know each other around here a lot
of the people
and
it's absolutely devastating absolutely
devastating to me for children like that
they've passed the house many times you
know
and the happy little children
yeah you know what can i say she was a
good man
you know
i saw them every day more or less when i
was walking in the park
uh with my dogs
because i've got some little dogs and
the children used to like
another young lady i spoke to who runs
or works on a market stall just here
said that she saw the boys every day as
they come and buy some fruit or
vegetables and describe them as very
happy and polite and she's extremely
saddened by this news the death of four
young children a week before christmas